president trump got some zingers in he
did
he did hit some points that were
substantive and i think you'd be able to
break out and put in some campaign
commercials
the first one was framing
this the the strongest issue for
democrats
health care that's the one they always
come back to even when health care has
absolutely nothing to do with the
election or the the issues at hand
so what president trump did was flip it
and show
how a joe biden presidency would destroy
american health care what i proposed is
that
we expand obamacare and we increase it
we do not
wipe any and one of the big debates we
had with 23
of my colleagues trying to win the
nomination that i won
were saying that biden wanted to allow
people to have private insurance still
they can they do they will under my
proposal
not what you've said right and it's not
what that party is saying that is simply
the party doesn't say your party wants
to go socialist
party
i am the democratic party right now your
party wants socialist medicine and
socialist health care and they're going
to dominate you joe you know that this
was a very smart framing here
which is not to say joe biden is a
radical he's a far leftist he's a
socialist
because nobody believes that joe biden's
been in office since before karl marx
was born
you know joe biden's been around a long
time he's positioned himself at various
times as a moderate
and at other times he's moved further to
the left
so that wouldn't be persuasive but what
we do know what is undeniable
is that joe biden is weak he's a weak
front-runner he's a weak leader of his
party he's a weak presidential nominee
and he will be swayed and dominated by
other members of the party
actually when that uh that communist
woman angela davis
uh this this awful far left uh woman
who is very influential in the
democratic party when she endorsed joe
biden
she said i'm endorsing joe biden not
because i think he's a radical but
because i think that we can
bully him into doing what we want same
thing is true
of bob avakian the head of the
revolutionary communist party in america
he said yeah i'm going to endorse joe
biden because we're going to be able to
bully him so that was the point
trump picked up on that i think is
persuasive because people who still
have horrible memories of obamacare
losing their doctor premiums going up
they're going to remember oh wait a
second joe biden's now promising more
socialist healthcare joe biden was in
part responsible for
for the obamacare mess i don't think i
want any part of that that was a good
singer
trump also got in one line they clearly
had written it out and rehearsed it
about a joe biden's pie in the sky
promises
and the likelihood that they're actually
going to come true he says he's smart
because he can take advantage of the tax
code and he does take advantage of the
tax code that's why
i'm going to eliminate the trump tax
cuts and we're going to we're
going to eliminate those taxes and make
sure that we invest in the people who in
fact
need the help people out there need help
but why didn't you do it over
the last 25 years because you weren't
president because you weren't president
screwing things up
you were a senator and you're the worst
president america has ever had
let me just tell you joe i've done more
in in 47 months i've done more than
you've done in 47 years joe
oh that's a good line that is some of
these scripted lines are not that good
and they kind of go over as groaners
which joe biden had one of those later
in the debate he said you
you say it's the heart of the deal you
do the art of the steal
ah please clap please it was like so
lame
but that's a good line i've done more in
47 months than you've done in 47 years
because you have to look at the timeline
of joe biden you say okay a guy gets
elected to the senate in 1973
senate senate senate senate senate
senate saying that's in the senate
senate vice president vice president
vice president vice president
vice president and he's out he's running
for office but now he's going to change
everything
now he just needed 46 years head start
and now starting in this 47th year now
he's going to change
everything trump made another good point
when when biden was hitting him on the
tax code
he said joe you wrote the tax bill
you're the one who gave me these tax
advantages so that was a good singer i
think you can break that out you're
going to see some t-shirts of i've done
more in 47 months and you've done in 47
years
and then i thought the best hit it was
the closest thing
that trump got to a clean hit of the
night it wasn't a major hit
but it's it could be somewhat useful is
joe biden was talking about how cops
like him so much
and trump said name one name one
law enforcement agency that supports you
he has no law that's enforcement look
who do you have name one group that
supports you name one group that came
out and supported you
go ahead i think we have time we don't
have time to do anything
all right one law enforcement group
that
and i want to get to another subject
which is the issue of protests in many
cities
that have turned violent gentlemen
gentlemen i have to interject here
because the president
just landed a brutal blow on joe biden
so we cannot
uh mr biden don't answer that i'll don't
i'll step in you obviously can't step in
but i'll step in
i'm chris wallace the moderator
yeah the mod is he's just trying to
moderate all of the attacks he's trying
to temper all of the attacks
that trump landed on joe biden so trump
landed some blows
okay joe biden also
landed some i wouldn't say he landed
blows he he just landed insults
they were both insulting one another i
felt trump got cleaner hits in against
joe biden joe biden for all the talk we
hear of civility
and the soul of america and how donald
trump is taking down the tone of our
public discourse
joe biden was much nastier and more
childish than donald trump
much it wasn't even close joe biden said
things that were shameful downright
shameful
to say to the president of the united
states called him a clown yelled at him
to shut up
and call them that classic the classic
insult that means it means any type of
bad person called him a racist
you agreed with bernie sanders on a plan
absolutely do you have any idea
socialized medicine mr president tell
you what vote now
make sure you in fact let people know
we're senators
i'm not going to answer the question
because you answered that because the
question is
the question is justice radical left
will you shut up
listen who is on your list joe this is
on your right
gentlemen i think this is
we have ended this segment we're going
to move on to the second segment that
was really a
productive segment wasn't it keep
yapping man the people
understand yeah 47 years you've done
nothing they understand
all right they were teaching people that
our country is a horrible place it's a
racist place
and they were teaching people to hate
our country and i'm not going to allow
that to happen vice president biden
nobody's doing that he's just he's
racist
here's the deal i know a lot more about
it
so unpresidential i'm not going to
defend
trump's badgering the whole night though
i actually i do have a point on trump's
badgering generally i felt it was
ineffective because he did it too much
but generally we will get to that
who was more or less presidential here
trump was much more presidential and i
get it that the badgering is
sort of tedious i get it it is
unacceptable childish stupid
disrespectful rude wrong
to tell the president of the united
states to shut up
i find that the phrase shut up to be one
of the
rudest phrases you can utter you have to
do it very selectively one time when
when ronald reagan was being shouted
down by a whole horde
of these awful anti-american hippies he
he famously told me goes oh shut up you
know he's like sort of half joking and
it
was
that was an effective use of that term
when you use that term
just in normal conversation it's
incredibly rude you could
you could instead use a much more vile
vulgar sort of word
and it would be less rude than that say
call him a clown the president of the
united states a clown
and then to say he's a racist
i i just don't that phrase
maybe at some point it had some meaning
it certainly doesn't anymore
george orwell in politics in the english
language said that the term fascist now
has no meaning it just means
some something that is not desirable
something that i don't like well
the same is true of racist there's no it
doesn't matter there's no
it even if somebody has racial bigotry
racial prejudices
the term doesn't matter the term even if
you walked up to david duke you walked
up to the head of the ku klux klan you
said you're a racist
the phrase itself has been deprived of
meaning because of people like joe biden
because he says you're ah i can't oh
well man i lost my train of thought and
i can't
gosh trump's off-footing me with the
badger you're a racist
you're a racist he's pathetic it's
totally pathetic
then at certain moments joe biden
actually
beyond the petty insults actually seemed
to undermine his own arguments
so when they were sniping each other
over the lockdowns
joe biden seemed to come out against the
lockdowns
i'll tell you joe you could never have
done the job that we did you don't have
it in your blood you could have never
done that yet
i know how to do the job i know how to
get the job well you didn't do very well
in swine flu
h1n1 you were a disaster your own
14 000 people died not 200 000 there was
no
economic recession
and there was no one there's no we
didn't shut down the economy
this is his economy that's been he's
shut down
what first of all
h1 i mean this is why the attack on h1n1
i see why trump launched it but
because the two diseases are so
incomparable
and then he tried to make that point
later right he said it was much less
lethal but because there's so
he left himself open to that that
counter-attack but i didn't expect joe's
counter-attack to say well we didn't
shut down the economy for h1n1
joe you're it's you guys who are trying
to shut down the economy now trump wants
to open the economy
and just five seconds ago you were
demagoguing the issue and saying trump's
killing people because he won't shut
down the economy
so what is it do the democrats want to
shut down the economy
or do they want to open up the economy
right now it's only the democratic
governors
practically who are trying to keep it
shut down right gavin newsom
uh the mayor eric our city in los
angeles andrew cuomo governor of new
york
bill de blasio mayor in new york it's
all the democrats who want to shut it
down
so but joe this is the trouble with
being a cynical
empty suit politician he doesn't have
any beliefs it's not just that he's
lying it's that he has no regard for the
truth so he says okay now it's
now it's good to hit him for the
lockdowns and it doesn't even occur to
him like wait a second but we were the
ones pushing the lockdowns
on him or arguing i just undercut our
argument that doesn't matter and i think
for a lot of his
partisans it probably won't matter much
either and then the most ridiculous
thing biden said all night
beyond the petty insults which you kind
of expect
he was he was asked to condemn antifa
and he held the party line he said
antifa doesn't exist
somebody's got to do something about
antifa and the left because this is not
a right-wing problem
this is a left-handed director this is a
left-wing
white supremacist antifa is an idea not
an organization you've got it
that's what his tonight fbi his fbi
director said well you know what no no
no we're not we're done sir
auntie we're done we're done mr trump
you can't please don't respond to that
because that statement that joe made was
so obviously indefensible
that uh please please don't respond we
got to move on new segment new site we
got
that's the sacred sacred news segment
antifa's an idea not an organization
antifa may be an idea but it's an idea
that has gotten into people's heads and
those people wear uniforms and they wave
a flag
and they march and organize together
that is an organization
you could say this you could say look
look fascism
is an idea it's not an organization
which is true
but in mussolini's italy that idea was
embodied by people who wore black shirts
and committed violence in the streets
nazism is an idea it's not an
organization sure it is an idea
it was embodied by people who wore brown
shirts and worked for adolf hitler in
germany
well communism is an idea it's not an
organization sure but it manifests in
organizations and antifa has a real
organization right now
coincidentally members of antifa are
alternately anarchists and
communists and all sorts of miscreants
and narrative wells and very bad
people we know that they i can see the
videos of them waving their flag
that is the definition of an
organization but they can't cop to it
and so
trump's getting a lot of flack right now
because they they pulled out the typical
court they say trump do you condem white
supremacists he goes sure
yeah okay yes of course i defend white
supremacists or do
i pardon me i condemn white supremacists
uh
who do you want me to condemn who do you
want me to condemn
and they say the proud boys okay yeah
proud boys go away okay yeah do we do it
but joe
you're defending antifa and joe says
there's no such thing as antifa
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode
linked in the description or download
the podcast wherever you listen to
[Music]
[Music]
podcasts